hello everyone and welcome to a really
really wild game from round one of the
tata still chess tournament 2021
uh it's magnus carlson versus alireza
ferrugia as we often like to refer to
this matchup the battle for the future
and uh like i said it's a really uh
crazy one and it's a very
interesting to see how players will
perform uh in classical chess after uh
so many so many online events so without
further ado
uh let's check it out as like i said it
it's uh it's really a wonderful game
uh so magnus with the white pieces opens
with
d4 uh we have knight to f6 violet is a
c4
e6 knight to f3 and weak transpose into
the queen's gambit decline we have d5
knight to c3 and now knight beat the d7
here
there are a lot of options for black
there are a lot of very
uh popular moves bishop to e7 is uh and
c6 are the most played moves and knight
b to d7 is like the the fourth most
common played move
so alireza not really going for the
absolute main line but still
of course magnus knows all of these
continuations uh so here
bishop to g5 and h6 now again
c6 is what's mostly played here h6 is
somewhat
rare so h6 first kicking back the bishop
to h4 and
only now bishop to e7 so continuing
development preparing to castle
and now magnus could also just continue
developing e3 develop the bishop and so
on but
magnus pretty much always is something
that i uh figured out when the queen's
gambit declined is on the board magnus
always captures c
captures on d5 so knight captures and
now
we have a trade here captures captures
and now e4 so magnus grabs the center
and uh now alireza can either move the
knight back or capture on c3
so knight captures in c3 b captures
yes this does improve carlson's center
but it's still
all uh all very known theory and alireza
is prepared for this we have castles
and bishop to d3 uh magnus is also ready
to castle now
and now there is a game in the database
where b6 was played but the move magnus
the movaliresa place is c5 and it is
already as of movie 11 that we have a
completely new game
yeah so let's see what happens here
magnus castles and now aleriza trades
once on d4
we have captures magnus recaptures and
now b6 so magnus still has his uh
very nice center here controls a lot of
squares here
and alireza is preparing bishop to be
seven to get his bishop to this
beautiful diagonal
and bring the rooks into the game
depending on how magnus plays and here
as alvareza by playing uh b6 gave magnus
a target magnus goes a4 he wants to play
a5 and trade off
his 8.4 for black's b pawn bishop to b7
and magnus immediately advances it with
a5
and now b captures an a5 uh if you don't
capture on a5
then it's just a very uh weird tension
going on here
where you want to capture on v6 when
black moves this knife from here but
black wants to be able to move the
knight so black doesn't want to
keep this tension there and if you move
the knight then captures black will have
to recapture with the a pawn
and then black loses his past a pawn
it's always nice to have your
passport on the edge of the board so
here b captures an a5
rook captures on a5 and now just knight
to f6
with a double attack on the e4 pawn and
magnus defends this rook to e1
and now rook f to d8 putting some
pressure on the d-file
and here magnus defends it yet again
with queen to a1 so adds additional
support to the d-pawn
but also there's now a double attack on
the a7 pawn but not really
uh as alireza defends it by playing
queen to c7 so defends it indirectly
because now if you go after after the
pawn then just captures captures and
rook to a8 the queen is now under attack
and the only move for magnus here is the
trade queens and
after this is all said and done captures
captures
uh these two points will be easy targets
for black and
alireza will at some point pick them up
for example rook v8 goes after the
bishop
and now if the bishop moves for example
c2 now a rook just here ended the pawn
will be recaptured but there are uh
plenty of other lines where
black also is successful in doing so so
after queen to c7
magnus doesn't go for the pawn of course
he goes h3 and now
a6 all it is uh strengthens the pawn
here and even though it's defended twice
and attacked three times it's still not
a good time to capture it
uh for example if you capture on a6 then
you have this problem of rook to d6 and
now
you cannot capture there's a triple
attack here on the bishop
and what do you do here now you cannot
capture because then you lose the rook
well you lose the exchange basically but
black will be better so instead after
a6 we have rook to c5 by magnus a nice
rook lift followed by rook to c5 a very
active square for the rook now
and alireza needs to decide whether to
go back with the queen queen d7 queen e7
or to be active with queen to f4 alireza
always goes for the active move so
queen to f4 and now uh as the e4 pawn is
attacked three times
by the queen knight and bishop uh magnus
defends it rook to e5 and here alireza
says okay
knight d7 uh we're attacking sorry
that's a rook
uh knight to d7 i'm attacking your rook
and you have to move it the rook
is quite passive here so magnus needs to
figure out something else
rook back to a5 and alireza repeats
knight f6 again a triple attack here
hoping for a repetition of moves
uh if the position is repeated uh three
times then of course it will be a draw
magnus as he does have the white pieces
and this is only move 22
not interested in a draw here went into
a sort of a deep thing
not a too deep of a thing uh some maybe
10 minutes
and then i decided to go for d5
d5 is a very nice breakthrough g3 was
also a very nice option here
but magnus prefers not to do it the
point of g3 is that you cannot capture
the knight if you capture the knight
rookie three
and the queen is captured there's no no
square available for the queen as the
rook covers the h5 square
so what you would have to do after g3 is
just retreat for example queen c7 and
then then you can strengthen your
position with king to g2
uh but magnus doesn't like this like we
said magnus after
this repetition of knight to f6 played
the d5 and this is a straight out pawn
sacrifice
uh to open up uh lines uh towards the
black king as you can see
so all it is that captures it you do not
want to allow the captures on e6 oh it
is a captures and now of course
e5 this is a well-known theme sacrifice
the d-pawn to advance the e-pawn and now
you've opened up this diagonal
and the knight needs to move now knight
the e4
and now comes queen to d4 a beautiful
centralizing move with the queen
and the knight cannot move now because
uh queen captures queen
will happen so here alireza goes back
rook
d to c8 now there's nothing on the c
file uh so alireza claims it for himself
we
rook the c8 and now uh now there's a
question uh whether whether you could
do something for example maybe you could
go for this rook captures and d5
seems like maybe reasonable idea for
example captures captures and captures
now your black snipe is attacked three
times but after this
uh very unpleasant knight the c3 there's
not all that much white
white can do here so it it really won't
uh be in
uh well any compensation for white so
instead
magnus goes rook back to a1 and this is
this is uh uh something he decided as
the rook cannot be any more active along
this
fifth rank and you will not be capturing
on d5 so magnus will try to activate it
uh
somewhere else for example the b file
will be will be a good option
uh here oh it is it just starts pushing
his passport alireza is not convinced
magnus has enough
compensation and he wants to advance now
uh his passport as far as possible
uh with rook 8 to b1 by magnus and now
bishop to c6 and here again a very
tricky position
magnus could go for something like rook
to b6 put put some pressure on this
bishop
and it's a very tricky move uh for
example if you go for rook a to b8 then
you get
the very unpleasant bishop to a6 and
already magnus is
magnus is close to winning because if
the rooks are traded queen captures and
there's now a double attack
this is attacked this is attacked and
you don't really have a good way of
defending
so what you would have to do after rook
to b6 is something like bishop to d7 but
this is already
very very hard to see queen captures on
d5
and now you have to move the knight
knight to c5 and it's a pretty crazy
position
where if alireza can defend and he
should be able to will just continue
pushing his pass pawn and it's going to
be fine
so magnus instead goes for another pawn
sacrifice and he pushes the pawn to e6
now he
opens up the queen's diagonal as well as
he already opened up
the the one belonging to the to the
light square bishop
and again you don't want to allow
something like pawn captures here so all
it is that captures it and not
knight the e5 so uh beautiful second
pawn sacrifice
to activate uh not only the the open
lines but also to
get a beautiful central square for this
knight and also there's now the
uh some pressure on this bishop here uh
and here
uh queen to f6 problem is here by moving
the knight
this is actually a very big threat for
example if alersa is careless pushes a4
just f3
and you win the knight the knight cannot
move because the queen hangs so
that's that's out of the question so
instead alireza went back
queen to f6 now uh magnus always has the
option of uh moving this knight for
example knight captures here then
you can trade queens but magnus is not
magnus is not interested in trading
queens and also the problem is if knight
captures on c6
then rook captures and c6 is also an
idea uh of course
that's how you're going to do it uh and
uh nothing here for magnus so magnus
needs to be very careful
here and he decides to go for f3
and this is a very tricky line he could
also just trade everything
and just to try and play this endgame
where he's going to be down upon
but uh not a lot of chances here for
example d captures an e4
knight captures on c6 now of course not
capturing with the queen because the
knight recaptures so just a rook
captures
and now we get this position and it's
just uh
just uh just a very nice position queen
captures on e4 and black should be
better
black is going to play something like
rook c to a6 start pushing his pass pawn
if he can
and enjoy his extra pawn but only black
can be better here
so instead after this queen to f6 move
with f3 by magnus uh still keeping it
very interesting but this is uh
this is a most adventurous move uh goes
back
knight to g5 and now only now rook to b6
with a double attack on this uh this
bishop here and also after after the
bishop moves the
rook will also be attacking the e6 pawn
so this is how magnus is planning to
to do a breakthrough now you could do a
bishop to d7 because the knight cannot
capture the queen hangs on d4
but all it uh uh goes all the way bishop
to e8 and it is in fact the better move
uh and here magnus goes for queen to e3
he unpins and now he wants to put
move the knight and put a lot of
pressure on this e6 pawn
also very interesting here was f4 but f4
again
magnus doesn't like his chances because
after knight f7 and
f5 which is just going all out you get
knight captures rook captures and now as
there's
so many pieces attacking this e6 pawn
rook the c6 and here after a nice trade
magnus could go for f captures an e6
creating a nice pass pawn here
but uh the bishop covers this square the
rook covers it and also
alireza still has this past eight point
which is incredibly strong so
uh magnus also not liking this so after
bishop to e8 we have queen to e3 by
magnus
and now a magnus of course is planning
to move the knight and go after this uh
e6 pawn here and here alareza should
wait
one more move before he starts pushing
his a4 pawn he should block
uh this knight he should play h5 block
the knights
access to the g4 square and only then
continue
with well depending on what magnus plays
however
uh alireza decided to go for a4 right
away he said okay this is not a problem
and magnus immediately played it knight
to g4
and now the problem is uh for example if
you go queen to e7 you get h4
and now what are you going to do with
the knight if knight goes knight goes
all the way back rook captures on e6
and this is now a a great position for
white
so alireza doesn't like this all it is
it goes back all the way not queen e7
but rather queen to d8 and puts pressure
on this rook so now
uh if the the queen moves the rook will
hang but magnus just of course
captures it with this rook so rook
captures an e6
uh and now uh well now
the thing is uh alireza can capture this
uh uh rook with the knight
but uh maybe maybe it's not the greatest
of moves maybe you should just continue
with a3
as that's what you've been doing
for the entire game but already decides
that it is okay to capture the rook and
it indeed it is okay to capture the rook
the engine doesn't mind this
but it uh comes with a with a very
tricky position because magnus
played queen captures an e6 with check
and now alersa should just play
king to h8 the thing is after king to h8
it's very hard for white to continue
this game uh
but uh uh we're we're gonna we're gonna
get back to this uh
because i might spoil it for you the
thing is after this queen the e6 check
alireza played bishop to f7 but now
uh well now it simply doesn't work and
i'm sure magnus was incredibly
happy when he saw this bishop to f7 move
because now magnus is completely winning
so feel free to pause the video here and
win the game for magnus uh while i give
you a couple of seconds
uh for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations and for those of you
uh who just want to enjoy the show it's
knight captures on h6
uh with check and now you don't really
have a good option here
uh because uh you you cannot you you
really can't move if you go king to f8
then just queen captures on f7 is
checkmate because the knight now also
covers that
if you go here then there's a double
attack on the bishop just knight
captures an f7
check and you're going into uh into a
nice discovery king's gonna go here
knight captures with check you have to
go back it doesn't matter where you go
because the bishop covers the h7 square
anything you do is checkmate so just a
queen to f7 checkmate
so uh after this knight captures an h6
uh move with
check alireza had to capture the knight
and now magnus captures it queen
captures on h6 and now there's a uh
there are a lot of problems here if you
don't react bishop to h7 is just a
a mating threat for example if let's say
black makes a silly move
like a3 just bishop to h7 check and you
you are getting made at king h8 it's a
famous mating pattern
bishop g6 check king here uh queen h7
czech king here and queen to f7 is
checkmate
so this is one of the first mating
patterns that you learn when you start
learning
mating patterns so of course alireza
defended against this right away he
played queen to c7
added a defender to the bishop here but
now
the game is completely lost for alireza
uh so feel free to pause the video once
again
it's a forced mate in six so while i
give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on
meeting uh young alireza in six moves
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show
it's queen to h7 with check and now
there's not much to be done king of f8
uh we have queen to h8 with check bishop
the king cannot reach the e file so
bishop to g8 is the only move and now
queen to h6 check
and it was in this position animal 40
that alireza furuja resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here of
course we're going to show what happens
now
uh there are two options either king f7
or queen blocks so if queen blocks
then we just get queen to d6 with check
and now there's nothing you can do
either you block with the queen and then
it's checkmate or you move the king to
f7 and then again queen to e7
is checkmate the bishop covers the g6
square so the black king
has nowhere to go and another thing
after queen to h6 check we said you
don't have to block you can play king to
f7
but it's not much better just bishop to
g6 with check
king f6 and now another great discovery
bishop to h5 with
check king to f5 and now g4 with
checkmate so kind of a nicer one uh but
we haven't seen any of these
so we don't know which one magnets would
go for s on queen to h6 check all it is
i resign the game
and uh an amazing victory for magnus
carlsen in round one of the tata still
chess tournament 2021
uh yeah yeah he said uh after the
previous tournament that he didn't
really
feel uh feel the moves that he couldn't
really get uh
any of the games he he played strong
moves he played incredibly strong moves
but that he
couldn't get the attacking games that he
wanted and here he really tried
everything he gave alireza chances by
risking so much but
uh like you've seen you had to be
extremely precise to
uh to to defend against this and i've
mentioned that we're gonna get back
go back to this position where alireza
played bishop to f7
the reason king the h8 works for alireza
but it's incredibly hard to find is
because the
following doesn't work now knight
captures on h6
as it was played in the game but now it
doesn't come with check
so what is the threat white is
threatening just checkmate here because
the bishop prevents the queen from
defending the square
so the only move here that saves black
is bishop to h5 so these are the two
moves that alireza had to fight in order
to properly defend here
now the queen defends uh against
checkmate and the bishop covers the f7
square
so there's no knight to f7 check uh
check winning the queen
and if queen to f5 going after this
checkmate
then you have queen b6 check king has to
move and then you pick up the knight
here so let's say king h2
you pick up the knight you defend
against mate you want a piece black is
winning here
uh but yeah incredibly hard move to find
after a queen to e6 check alareza for
some reason immediately blocked with the
bishop and it was just
all over uh so really really
really crazy stuff but yeah
amazing start uh to the tournament for
magnus not the greatest of stars for
alireza uh but i i it's
it's it's how it is you know that there
are still plenty of more rounds and
we'll see what happens
uh so yeah uh that's uh the game hope
you guys enjoyed it the battle for the
future continues
uh i would like to thank um vincent
saborin resvana beer uh andrey agostini
dimitrios
chrissy kopoulos and mohsen razay for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and
i will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the tata steel chess
tournament
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day